I want to talk about the Senate
Intelligence hearings that's a big story
I don't know I'm just asking people
generally Andy Andy do have any thoughts
about the Senate Intelligence hearings
well nothing fresh or insightful but I
can spout empty meaningless media
cliches empty meaningless media cliches
Andy are you proposing that we have a
good old-fashioned media cliche battle
[Applause]
here we go now the topic the topic is
the Senate Intelligence hearings over
Trump's connections to Russia and II
what are your thoughts well I'll say
this Conan there's more here than meets
the eye
I agree one thing's for sure we haven't
heard the last of this story no sir and
how it affects the Trump administration
is anyone's guess because at the end of
the day it is what it is yeah exactly
old pal Trump bit off more than he could
chew and commis testimony was just the
tip of the iceberg because where there's
smoke there's fire and when Trump told
the Russians that Comey was a nut job
not only was the pot calling the kettle
black
he also awoke a sleeping giant and now
he's up shits Creek without a paddle
[Applause]
I mean Trump is down but he's not out
I mean sure by going after the FBI
director he opened a can of worms and he
can't unring that Bell
but was it obstruction of justice I
think the jury is still out well well
Jeff Sessions testifies tomorrow
everyone's waiting for the other shoe to
drop but this investigation is a
marathon not a sprint
so you think Trump is playing the long
game huh I'm saying he could run out the
clock well I guess it ain't over till
it's over you got that right
a man can't whistle when his pants are
on fire
[Music]
I'm sorry Ani I am sorry a man can't
whistle when his pants are on fire is
not an official cliche looks like we
tied at 10 and you know what they say
about ties they always go to the runner
you know Conan you're a big [ __ ]
wait that's a cliche oh yeah everyone
around here says it all the time
you
you